guys there's two new dudes we gotta go
out there what's in there that's a good
question high five right the ladies of
love island came a-runnin for two new
bronze bros that made their way to
beautiful Fiji leaving the other man
feeling a little territorial Nene this
is love after the island hey sexy
features welcome to love after the
island your official love Island recap
show i'm lauren zima here to spill all
the tropical tea on this major first
week of love island airing only on CBS
and CBS all access and joining me now to
weigh in on our first week of hookups
and shake ups is the amazing jack of
Vanek a co-host of the lady gang girl I
know you're a love island superfan I am
the super fan so I could not be more
excited to be here
I loved Thursday night's episode I felt
like each episode just gotten more and
more dishy all week long and then cormac
and Dylan came in their energy where Mac
is like c4 Cormac c4 confident and Dylan
was like such a bro Gillian is the
ultimate bro he reminds me of every guy
that I've dated in the past so I have
something like deep inside me that
really feels for him like record I'm
triggered I I want him to be mine I
think we both looked at them and said
these are the kinds of guys who you see
them in a bar and you think that guy's
gonna run my life they both will in
different ways yes but wait leave her
John Mary is like my perfect no really
yeah I love him he's so hot she said
John Mayer about 62 times this week John
Mayer you know let's get you on the love
island train you can come here to love
after the island because you're being
talked about wait wouldn't that be the
biggest twist ever if John Mayer just
started walking in like at the very end
when she's in like an amazing
relationship and he's just playing your
body as a wonderland like I'm here baby
I made it this episode Thursday night
though was so good I felt like
Mack and Dylan came in and shook things
up the women ran out to them and you
could see the fear the cuts okay Michael
his reaction to opening the door and
looking out he's like uh-uh because the
guys this is their first week nobody's
come in yet to shake things up so I'm
sure that they think that they're
they're cool they're confident they're
in their couples they're fine nothing's
gonna matter even if they don't really
like the girls that much but it's about
to get crazy
oh they got a taste of their own
medicine because they were all all about
Kiera when she came in and now the
ladies were all about these guys and I
felt like we got a lot of insight into
Carmack's personality based on the way
he was approaching the women talking
about them I want to play this clip of
Cormac kind of giving his general review
on the ladies appearances and their lack
thereof with makeup we've seen them with
no makeup on right which i think is
great
yeah because sometimes when you meet a
girl who's like dolled up and then you
see him without makeup and you're like
[Laughter]
I'm saying Dean like I'm definitely
attracted to all the girls here so I
know they're all really pretty yeah I
don't comment you know what it is it's
one of those things I think where it's
okay for us to say but yeah I'm not okay
for the I to say I could talk about my
weight but you cannot talk about my
wedding what he said that you and I are
both like not okay so that might be
foreshadowing some personality quality
is that I don't think that women will
really like based on the tightness of
his pants I think that we can assess
that Cormac is about the visuals we got
some sizzling tea tonight as the two new
bros came in the other bros got really
bro e and they did not have a
conversation without working out they
are lifting weights in ways that I felt
were not actually productive to getting
fit Yaman was lifting a five 10 pound
weight I think over his head it was an
interesting thing I'm like dude you're
just getting in this vibe to have the
conversation but you're not you're not
doing both know a Feld's forced and we
also saw bros in bed yeah they were
shirtless which I sort of loved you
usually see a cute moment where women
are kind of having this sleep a moment
chatting but I liked that our original
guys they isolated Cormac and Dillon I
know
they just got under the sheets together
to really talk about things what
happened oh man and it's so cute it's
the girl I'd like to couple up with is
manner used to being that intimate with
each other right and it's nice because
in this love island house it kind of
forces you to have these conversations
about vulnerability and love and who
you're liking in your feelings yeah
they're not used to that but I really
like seeing it it's really cute tell me
who you are loving as a couple I love
Elizabeth and Zach they feel like
they're gonna be the ones that'll maybe
make it to the end because there's the
initial attraction and then they vibe
but you never know well an Elizabeth was
getting talked to by Dylan getting
talked to by Cormac but she was like
stand by oh man although we saw at the
end of Thursday night Cormac then got
the text he could ask anyone out and he
asked how Elizabeth or Magus called he's
late night he's Savage I'd love for you
to join me on a date tonight Cormac wait
what like Elizabeth that literally told
him I'm not that into you and he still
has surrounded Jack he wants what he
can't have
yes there's trouble in paradise yes and
we also saw Cormac talked to Kira a
little bit before he ended up going on a
date with Cairo and we were dying over
this moment Cashel in the most subtle
way was making his presence to do oh my
god
I've never seen anything like this
the quiet confidence of cashel to think
you know I'm gonna let my woman know I'm
here in these dad goggles in the pool
like it was my rope
it was the best thing I've ever seen it
you could not have planned that it is so
me mobile if you guys are watching
please make this a meme I just want it's
like you know me eavesdropping on my
co-workers conversations and you're just
swimming just like a casual on the
background while he's literally stealing
your girl oh he does have this quiet
subtle confidence that I like yes
because nobody picked him in the
beginning remember and then all the
girls kind of started creeping back in
yeah and want him and he's just playing
it cool I'm seeing Cashel and Cormac
maybe having a bit of a showdown Cashel
actually looks like the love child of
Cormac and Dillon to me like he looks
like the two of them combined he does he
does so much has changed so quickly here
on love Island and one thing you don't
want to be on love Island is all talk
and
action a kiss is worth a thousand words
these are our game-changing smooches of
the week I'm going in mean what do you
think
[Music]
another one I definitely didn't know
that Kara was gonna go in for like the
full make out the neverending kiss from
Kara
it was weird I love Elizabeth and Zack I
love them but I have got to say is my
biggest nightmare to make out on
television so they they all make me
cringe a little bit it's just the sounds
of kissing and stuff but I mean
elizabeth is a Kirk you here's what I
loved about our kisses first kiss little
face grab for the your second kiss Carol
goes in for that long face grab by that
last kiss Elizabeth and Zack both
grabbing each other's faces I think a
face grab makes a big difference oh if
it you have to have a face cracks is not
romantic or you-tube what do you think
not at kissing Colin what are you doing
with their hands put him on down here
you know like grab it yes there kiss was
the only one that I felt like had
anything behind it it was real love
feelings there yeah I'm seeing some
depth there I mean Kara's kiss was I am
doing anything I'm desperate please like
me bad as she knew that he was gone yeah
I feel right now the strongest couples
are Kira and Cashel because Cashel was
very rejecting of Karos kiss he's in for
Kira yeah and Elizabeth and Zack yeah
there are the frontrunners you never
know what's still I'm gonna do that's
what I care about
okay who do you want to see Dylan with I
just love him I just want to see him say
I think Elizabeth is too good hearted
and sweet for that Cormac yes not on the
date I know maybe Cormac and Keira I
don't know he needs a little spice
though I actually could have seen him in
Keira that's why I'm sensing a showdown
between cash land Cormac I think that's
gonna happen
there's a recent drama I already feel it
the first week saw awkward kisses
relationship misses straight up disses
but somehow our iconic Islander of the
week managed to keep that kero coaster
of emotion in constant motion let's take
a ride on the Cairo train so the boy
that I want a couple up with is
actually a really good choice he's a
great guy do you have to choose my match
just so like ridiculous so I just felt
like kind of like disrespected in a way
because it's like you guys couldn't even
just like talk to me about it Cormack
america has been voting and i decided to
send you on a date with Carol that's
cheers to America voting for us to be on
our first day hopefully not our last one
okay so you like me by the way a quick
[ __ ] - Michael the model for all the
face he served this episode he was like
wow again he's a meme I need him being
so mad in the background like oh no
Carol I think Caro is fascinating
television because gold is all in in
she's all in she's all over the place
she is I'm here for if she what's she
gonna do next I know she's crying over
casual she's all in on Cormac I'm just
I'm in love three times already
there's only six guys she's gone through
half dates dates it's been days so Caro
has now gone off with Cormac McCormack's
about to take out Elisabeth literally
things are moving so fast and on
Thursday night we were hearing people
say you know one of my best friends in
the house or I had these these feelings
are happening so strong so fast oh yeah
I've heard that a day on love Island is
like a week or a month in real life
there's so many things that could change
so you never know how do you feel about
our adorable Yaman and Alanna kebab
I love Yaman he was one of my favorites
when he walked in I loved him in Weston
where my two faiths so I mean we haven't
seen that much of them I'd like to see
more cuz I think he's really goofy and
funny yeah but I think that they could
be like a sleeper couple it's she is
super chill she seems like an incredibly
easy person to go through and so I could
see them sticking it out so Dylan is
about to go on a date with Mallory that
I will see next week and they are Barbie
and Ken to me and I'm so here for it
yeah her look together but I don't know
enough about either of them to know if
they would vibe cuz he seems like he has
such a good connection with Alexandria
they just have that instant sort of
pantry vibe yeah I just want
aesthetically I'm like it's just her
being kind of my Malibu party they're in
the moment together
all right my dear I want to play a game
with you okay because you are such a
love island fanatic and of course the
host of lady gang we have put together
lady gang or boo thing so I'm gonna read
off the guys on the show okay and I want
you to tell me if you would see them as
a friend in the lady gang or datable boo
thing you're vibing them so Yaman boo
boo thing for sure okay he's so hot oh
love him yeah he's great he's very tall
I mean he could put a couple more pounds
on his way to he's lifting but he's so
fast and so I'm like what what is
happening Zach our little grocery store
music god baby see he's so cute but like
not as like a booty he'd be a lady gang
mm-hmm I feel like he'd end up being my
little buddy that's so cute gives me
little brother vibes in the way that I
want him and Elizabeth to work out like
I've shipped them together yes but
you're yeah but you're ten me yes
Michael
our male model Michael I would make out
with so you'd be a boo thing but booth
hanging breeze poofing poofing for one
night Oh perfect our quiet confident
casual C casual I feel like I would
think would be a lady gang I feel like
he'd be a buddy
but again he's got those sneaky vibes
and then it'd be one of those things
you've known him for a couple weeks
couple months you're like I think I love
you right
when did this happen or like wait a
minute I've trusted you with all of my
life secrets and I've actually talked to
you about other guys but are you the one
and now you've put a spell on me yes
he's the rom-com guy you know all of a
sudden you're in love with him he's
Ashley I feel like probably gets girls
not that he's not cute but probably way
out of his league and he's just like I
don't know I just have the magic touch
casual touch he doesn't change like the
tone or the volume of his voice yeah and
I think he's then says these things you
don't realize you're kind of mesmerized
the casual casual captivation love it
I'm hoping for more of those kisses you
know what I mean Weston are cowboy boo
boo thing for sure really
yeah Westen's my vibe okay I like a
blonde
love blond man and he's fun he loves
country music
he's just a good time dude like he's the
guy that I would like long-term dating
boo thing oh yeah serious boo thing yeah
seriously thing moving to our new Bros
Oh Dylan boo bang he's I'm saying in
brief or long-term booth hmm how much
have you grown as a personal jack that's
what we're about to find out are you
answering this in your years ago cell
for your current state this is my years
ago so okay it would be who I thought
would be my boo thing long-term who
would end up ghosting me yes it's the
Ken vibe but player underneath sort of
thing like he's very nice but you know
he's talking to five girls at once the
difference between human Cormac is that
I feel like you were just no Cormac we
got to play you yes but Dylan's keeping
it under the radar yes he's a secret
little player yeah you could see in some
of the language I mean Cormac straight
up saying I wonder how good they look
without makeup on or not but then Dylan
when he's talking to Alexandra is saying
things like yeah I was definitely
possibly gonna pick you yeah yeah and
you're like wait did you just insult me
it's it's a very subtle manipulation
that I always fall for okay all right so
Dylan we're gonna watch out for you and
finally our boy Cormac Cormac oh not my
type but honestly another one night boo
thing okay yeah cuz you know he's one of
those guys that if you meet him in a bar
he's got swag he knows how to talk to
girls and he could probably pick anybody
up so he's got good mood I'd fall for it
for sure we have an enjoyable night with
Cormac we'd have an enjoyable night very
excited to watch him and Carole and all
that okay so we only had a couple in the
lady gang it sounds like we're open to
more as booth Hanks we are in brief or
in length I I need some more boo things
I'm waiting for him to walk through
however Dylan I'll have many day oh my
god we love that do any so triggering
all right that has been lady ganger
booth bang thank you jack you know you
guys you can still be on love Island you
can still head to our website and
audition and guys we have officially
filled our love tank for this week our
special thanks to the gorgeous fabulous
hilarious Jack Van Eyck for all of her
superfan insight be sure to check Jack
out on lady gang and the first degree a
totally addictive true crime podcast
left your grandpa
Plus be sure to tune in to a love island
five nights a week only on CBS and CBS
all access and every Friday we are back
here for a weekly keiki to discuss all
the ins and outs of love island will
have exclusive content from the
Islanders of themselves plus fabulous
celeb guests to weigh in on oh the
tropical tea you won't want to miss it
from our cozy Cabana here in California
thank you again Jack Korres thank you
I'm Lauren Zima stay cool sexy beaches
[Music]
[Applause]